ميسون نحن الان امام منزل وليد الغريبي
الذي قتل فيه يوم الاثنين الماضي
التحقيقات لا زالت جاريه حتى اللحظه ااا
دعيني اشير بانه هذا هو المندل الذي قتل
فيه وليد الغريبي وتحديدا في الطابق
الثالث من هذا المنزل
هذا الحي الذي يتواجد فيه المنزل هو من
الاحياء الفقيره التي تعد نسبيا في مدينه
فيلادلفيا
يسكن فيه دمه داخل المنخفض حقيقه همم
وايضا همم تسكن فيه غالبيه همم سكان
امريكاين همم من اصول افريقيه همم قبل
دقائق تحديدا ميسون تواصلنا مع صاحبه هذا
المبنى التي ذكرت لنا بانه همم هذا
الحادثه التي حصلت يوم الاثنين وانها تعرف
وليد الغريبي وذكرت لنا بانه
ولد خلوق جدا همم هو مستاجر في هذا المنزل
وتحدثت عنه باسهاب وكانت تبكي لانها خسرت
كما ذكرت صديق رائع وذكرت ايضا بانه همم
نيكول ميري التي ارتكبتها المتهمه بارتكاب
هذه الجريمه كانت مستاجره من قبل همم ار
بي ان بي وهذا الموقع الذي يسمح باشاره
المنازل لايام عده نيكول مريء استاجرت همم
غرفه في هذا المنزل لمده 18 يوما ولم تكمل
18 يوما همم اعتبرت ملكه هذا المنزل بانه
همم ميريكان لديها مشكله مع وليد الغريبي
لم تعرف سببها ملكه المنزل لم تحدثنا عن
تفاصيلها طلبت همم منها بانه همم فقط ان
الطول بانه همم وليد كان من افضل الزبائن
الذين تعاملت معهم في هذا المنزل وقبل
دقائق ايضا ميسون التواصلت معنا الشرطه
فيلادلفيا ومكتب المختص بمتابعه هذه
القضيه تحديدا وارسل لنا همم بريد
الكتروني ذكر بانه لا
نتبع المعلومات المتداوله حول هذا هذا هذه
القضيه تحديدا لانها غير صحيحه وانه سيتم
مشاركتنا بكل التفاصيل الصحيحه فور انتهاء
التحقيقات اذا التحقيقات لا زالت جاريه
حتى اللحظه همم نيكول ميري همم لا زالت لا
زالت هاربه من من قبل السلطات حتى اللحظه
وحتى همم بانه الشرطه شاركتنا الصوره
الخاصه
للمتحمه وايضا ب همم نمره لوحه السياره
الخاصه بالمتهمه من الجدير ذكره همم ميسون
بانه هذا الحي همم
تامنا تماما وان عناصر الشرطه دائما ما
تتواجد فيه حتى انهم طلبوا منا بانه بان
نبقى تحت انظارهم لانهم لا يستطيعوا
التامين سلاماتنا حتى همم نكون تحت انزارا
تعالى دائما نتمنى لكم السلامه
وابقوا حذرين